in eastern Ukraine a rare public
appearance little is known about the two
Russian paramilitary groups that claimed
the attack on belgarod but their
ambition is clear the Russian volunteer
Corps and Liberty of Russia Legion say
they want a topple President Vladimir
Putin the groups based in Ukraine say
they acted independently and Belgard is
just the beginning
everything we do within the state
borders of Ukraine we obviously
coordinate with Ukraine military of
course because otherwise we would have
been Russians with machine guns running
around Ukraine in Wartime obviously
everything we do every decision we make
behind Beyond The Border behind the
state border is our own decision
but its groups were founded last year
made up of Russians who used to fight in
Ukraine's International Legion the
Kremlin says they couldn't have acted
alone and Kiev was behind the raid
top advisors says Kiev was not involved
but welcomes any disruption to moscow's
Ware we are not involved in any internal
events in Russia however what happened
in the Belgard region proves that Russia
is gradually losing control they are
unable to protect their own borders
because their troops are concentrated in
occupied Ukraine
oliac says keeves reassured its allies
about its role Ukraine's allies Supply
Kiev with weapons on the understanding
that it will never carry out attacks on
Russian soil and risk escalating the
conflict
pictures like this though are making
NATO allies anxious Moscow says this
video shows us-made armored vehicles in
Belgrade some of the reports circulating
on social media and elsewhere making
claims that U.S supplied weapons were
used in these attacks I will say that
we're skeptical at this time of the
veracity of these reports
not part of the paramilitary groups
linked to Belgrade but he's another
Russian fighting for change once a
senior executive at Russia's state-owned
gazprom Bank he defected to Ukraine and
joined its Foreign Legion
Russia will not only lose this war it is
already losing Russia will pay for this
for many many decades not only
financially but they'll be pointed out
be put on trial or spat on for years
they'll be ashamed to walk around with a
Russian passport
the Belgard attack was the biggest
incursion into Russia since the War
Began evidence that while Putin wages
war in Ukraine he also faces the threat
of more attacks on Russian soil
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev